what kind of life
survives up there on top of this
volcanoes it's about bacteria you know
mostly is there something specific about
that bacteria that's able to be so
rugged yes
um they have adapted to very high UV
radiation and it's not only because they
are at high altitude it's because early
Earth
didn't have an ozone layer so when those
the ancestors of those bacteria
originated they have to survive a world
where you had lots of short UV coming
down at the surface and also lots of
hydrothermal environment you know
volcanoes and hot water lots of salt and
you see all these toolbox
teal
embedded in those microorganisms today
four billion years later it's just
amazing and depending on the environment
they are going to switch some of these
defenses adaptation on or off
the UV situation there is so nasty that
here you have bacterias like that I know
bacteria you find them everywhere it's
really something you find all over the
place but if you find them here in
California they will turn their
protection against UV during the day in
summer and they will switch it off at
the end of the day
there in the Andes it's so nasty is that
that thing stays on all the time
but if you take samples and bring them
back here and start to
culture them
like we did on top of a building leaving
them you know you will see the second
generation of this organism they are
starting to switch on and off again
so they're extremely adaptable extremely
rugged and that's why they are still
here
and probably that's why we are here
because life found sways so is there
some degree to which the harshness of
the conditions
enables
the flourishing of life versus shuts it
down
well it will shut down those that cannot
survive obviously you know this is a
statement that's Captain Obvious right
there but it's also
the survival of the fittest and this is
what evolution is right
so they are here because they were the
most deductible
and so
evolution is going to show the path of
the fittest the one that cannot resist
they might have a good time for a little
while but then you know we've seen this
at much different scale and with complex
life not so long ago a hundred thousand
years ago
meanderthal
was side by side by Homo sapiens but
nandatho was completely adapted to a
cold Earth to a glacial Earth of the end
of the pleistocene
and when condition change
it couldn't last you think I mean
there's still some Mysteries around that
right like exactly exactly what were the
harshness of the conditions
um I still really suspicious what did
Homo sapiens do no no no I really want
to know no no Shady stuff that happened
shitty stuff happened they met the bread
together the father get each other
what humans do you had to expect that
but the thing is that Neanderthal was
completely adapted for a very long time
to leave at the edge of those glaciers
there were probably in a weekend
situation when Homo sapiens came uh and
and started to spread so
um basically this is what life does it
adapts and if you cannot add apps
anymore it disappear and something else
takes over